in July of 1965 during x-men number 12
Marvel introduced one of the most
prominent adversaries of the x-men and
one of the most popular supervillains a
man named Cain Marko who developed
virtually unrivaled physical strength
and durability after picking up a gym
and reading the following inscription
whosoever touches this gym shall be
granted the power of the crimson gem of
cyttorak henceforth you who read these
words shall become forevermore a human
juggernaut what's goin on guys this is
rob and today we're going to be talking
about the juggernaut
so the juggernaut or Cain Marko is the
result of a very troubled childhood of
course he wasn't a murderous child like
Cletus Kasady but he was the victim of
constant abuse both emotional mental and
physical at the hands of his father
in addition que marco is the stepbrother
of Charles Xavier and the reason for
this is because Charles Xavier father
and Kane Marcos father worked very
closely to one another and when Charles
Xavier father died Kane Marcos father
married Charles Xavier mother for her
wealth as a result since Cain Marco had
been booted out of virtually every
boarding school he had been sent to he
was moved in with the family at the same
time Kane Marcos father really kind of
displayed a favoritism of sorts towards
Charles Xavier and so as a result this
rift kind of formed between Charles
Xavier and Kmart okay Marko viewed
himself as kind of the cast-off the
black sheep of the family and not really
someone that was desirable as being a
child of his father and he looked at
Charles Xavier as though the child that
the Charles Xavier was was the child
that his father wished he had now
ultimately this this rift really kind of
comes to a head and it becomes
irreparable irreparable when Kane Marcos
father dies and Cain Marko overhears his
father's last words directed to Charles
Xavier when he tells Charles do not let
people know that you had these
telepathic powers because the world's
not ready for it yet prior to this point
there had been a few instances where
Charles Xavier had used his powers
unintentionally on Cain Marko and Kane
Mach who had been aware of this but at
this point came Marco believed that it
had been done intentionally and so
because of this he could really kind of
hated Charles Xavier from this point
forward and viewed Charles Xavier as his
his arch enemy so to speak now we don't
really know a lot about what Cain Marko
got into between the time that he and
Charles parted ways after his father's
death and the time that he and Charles
were reunited during the Korean War what
we do know is that somewhere along the
line Cain Marko became a mercenary and
he was involved in a third world nation
in a revolution that was taking place as
part of the revolutionary forces because
of the fact the Rev
forces were defeated Kane marker was
thrown in jail where he met his future
Ally black Tom Cassidy the cousin of
banshee and also kind of the black sheep
of his own family although he
intentionally chose to become a villain
a black Tom Cassidy used his abilities
to help him inkay Marko escaped and then
came Marko again kind of became a
mercenary for time shortly after of
course he and Charles Xavier reunited
during the Korean War which is when Cain
Marko finds the temple of CID Iraq reads
the inscription for the crimson gem of
cyttorak and is imbued with a fraction
of syntax powers now in order to
understand CID Iraq in order to
understand the powers that the
juggernaut has we need to do a little
bit of backstory here CID Iraq is one of
eight deities that had previously roamed
the earth around a thousand years before
Cain Marko found the crimson gem of sin
Iraq and at the time there was a
disagreement of sorts between these
these deities these entities as to which
one was the most powerful and so they
agreed on something called the wager or
the war of octet sense and what they did
is they each created an artifact and
within that artifact
they put a fraction of their power now
what they also did is they created
temples and they cast a spell and what
would happen is the first mortal that
touched this particular artifact or an
artifact belonging to one of the deities
would trigger the spell which would
cause a kind of mad dash for the other
artifacts to be discovered once all of
the artifacts would be discovered the
possessors of those artifacts would
divide humanity into groups of eight and
they would each control one-eighth of
humanity after bending the will of
humanity to their own in turn they would
pit humanity in a war against itself and
whichever I guess possessor of the
artifact came out on top would in effect
prove that their deity was the strongest
now with regards to Kain Marcos power as
the juggernaut because of the fact that
he possesses a fraction of silver acts
powers his powers are essentially
extreme physical strength virtually
unrivaled physical strength extreme
durability and to a degree force fields
and different things like that but for
the sake of this discussion we're going
to really focus on the mainstays of his
and that is his physical strength and
his durability the juggernaut does not
require any sustenance or air to survive
he requires no food no water nothing he
can survive in the vacuum of space for
time now it can't be everlasting of
course eventually the extreme
environment of space would would get to
him but with the helmet that he has on
his head this also protects him from
mental manipulation and this is really
the only weakness of juggernaut and it's
something that we've seen exploited
several times in the Marvel Comics most
often by Charles Xavier himself or Jean
Grey or someone who possesses vast
telepathic powers and somehow it needs
to overcome the juggernaut to achieve a
particular goal now with regards to the
juggernauts physical power his physical
strength there is only one one
earthbound character that has been able
to challenge him physically in terms of
strength and we'll quantify this
statement here in a second but the only
earthbound character that was able to
challenge him was of course the
Incredible Hulk and the Age of
Apocalypse storyline in which the
Incredible Hulk was the horsemen war for
apocalypse and when a person is made
into a Horsemen of apocalypse their
existing powers are enhanced several
times over and if they have no existing
powers they are granted extreme powers
and in this instance the Incredible Hulk
strength was increased several times
over now when I say that we needed to
quantify this what I mean to say is that
there are some earthbound characters
that can defeat juggernaut but these are
characters who are wildly powerful Jean
Grey as the Phoenix horse Franklin
Richards you know with the ability to
manipulate matter on an extreme scale
mad Jim Jasper's who can manipulate
matter on an extreme scale proteus
different characters like that these are
characters it has such extreme abilities
that their powers don't rest within the
realm of physical strength and in fact
physical strength isn't relative or
isn't relevant to what it is that they
can do because it just it wouldn't
really hinder their powers
now with the juggernaut in terms of his
goals he's a perfect example of a
dim-witted bully who has granted
extraordinary abilities he's not very
smart he's for the most part
unintelligent
I mean he has a measure of intelligence
don't get me wrong but it is a little
below average relative to the average
human being that we see in Marvel Comics
his real goal his goal for the most part
is to really just kind of defeat Charles
Xavier to kill him
this is driving factor in life which is
really kind of funny because if you were
to take someone who had a higher level
of intelligence say for example someone
like Charles Xavier and were to give him
the powers of sitter at the extreme
durability extreme physical strength
they could use them for a multitude of
different things and in fact there was
actually a point in the Marvel Comics I
don't remember the name of the kid but
there was a point in which juggernaut
through the crimson Jim into space and
it was bumped back into into Earth's
orbit and crashed back into the planet
after being hit by nova and there was a
young kid who found the found the gym
and used the gym for his own purposes
and he was able to manipulate all
different kinds of things he can
manipulate computers all across the
world he could make all the computers
function as if they were operating in
one will kind of like Skynet and
terminator so to speak he was able to
manipulate the gym in ways that had
never been conceived of my Ken Marcou
but again this does not mean that Cain
Marko is someone that cannot that should
not be taken seriously and in fact
during the first encounter with the
juggernaut in the x-men comics Charles
Xavier tells the x-men be very very
careful because this man possesses a
physical strength which none of you can
match he will destroy all of you if you
allow him to so with that being said I'm
gonna go and bring this video to an end
I hope you guys enjoyed it if you did
let me know and I will catch you guys
later peace